this company adds a modern twist to the
classic will be by recipe in addition to
traditional chocolate and vanilla the
company makes for other all-natural
flavors the ingredients are certified
vegan non-gmo gluten-free kosher and
free of many common food allergens
workers begin by making the chocolate
cakes the first ingredient is water
followed by apple cider vinegar then
they add either canola or sunflower oil
they mix the liquid ingredients in a
large bowl then they add the dry
ingredients starting with tapioca starch
bean flour and sorghum a gluten-free
grain
next they mix in cocoa powder granulated
cane sugar and light brown sugar
they run the mixer at a very high speed
to incorporate air in the batter this
will make the cake lighter and fluffier
after about four minutes of mixing the
batter is ready they test a sample using
a viscometer a device that measures the
thickness if the batter is the right
consistency they pump it through a
hopper into a multi head depositor each
of its five nozzles shoot one ounce of
batter onto a moving baking sheet a
finished sheet contains seven rows of
batter workers load multiple sheets of
batter into an oven the sheets rotate
for 15 minutes at 75 degrees Fahrenheit
evenly baking the cakes the precise
combination of ingredients allows the
acids in the apple cider vinegar to
react with the cocoa powder the result
is a perfect little chocolate cake
that's rich in flavor and moist in
texture the main ingredient for the
filling is shortening it's made from
sustainable palm oil
this means the palm trees were
responsibly harvested they mix the
shortening well incorporating enough air
to make it light and fluffy then they
add powder cane sugar and organic rice
milk as a dairy-free substitute
the rice milk makes the frosting creamy
for vanilla frosting
they simply add pure vanilla extract
this is a batch of raspberry frosting so
they add pure raspberry extract and beet
juice for color when they make mint
frosting they use pure mint extract and
alfalfa extract for green color lemon
frosting is made from pure lemon extract
and tumeric for color they check the
shade against a color chart to ensure
the correct flavor the multi-head
depositor drops frosting on the baking
sheets in the same configuration as the
batter
then they assemble the final pie workers
start by placing a piece of cake on top
of the frosting they press down hard
enough to spread the frosting just shy
of the cakes edge they cover the top
with a sheet of parchment paper then
place a baking sheet on top and flip it
over they remove the top baking sheet
and the parchment paper then they
carefully place the second cake onto the
frosting
workers roll the trays of whoopie pies
into a corner where the desserts chill
for about 15 minutes
this hardens them and so they won't get
squished during packaging workers place
the whoopie pies on a conveyor belt that
leads to an automated rapping machine it
wraps double printed packaging around
each pie and seals them underneath then
the Machine cuts the film between each
pie the next machine package is for
sealed whoopie pies per retail box there
are zero preservatives in these will be
pies they're shipped frozen to the
grocery store and sold in the freezer
section when it's time for a treat
simply let them thaw to room temperature
and enjoy